es kommt zu einem video sang wieder auf
meinem channel heute mit diesen zwei
mitgestalten wir sind in köln unterwegs
ist weder gamescom video daisy gehen
heute auf die video days und nehmen euch
einfach mal mit weil wir diese geht hier
alleine auf die video ist nein wir gehen
zu dritt und leicht wieder wenn
marktstrategien ich bin dankbar für mein
ticket vergessen das heißt wieder zurück
und schauen finden damit wir dann hier
auf den video
gekostet
und hier können wir richtig billig war
nintendo 64 spielen die ist das super
danke an den tender für dieses tolle
produkte spaß jedenfalls sehr viele
eingerichtet auf dem holztisch ihren und
lauter youtube machen die menschen hier
richtig gut und sagen wir sind wieder
wenn wieder passiert bin ich rutsche
die boys wir spielen jetzt auf den 64
hallo
zwischen lounge immer noch
ich habe hier sind wir ein wildes hallo
hallo so heute besitzen gerade unterwegs
bewegen durch diese lanxess arena und
versuche uns jetzt irgendwie irgendwie
lounge einzuschleichen und leute
angehalten werden fotos machen als er
merkt ist richtig undercover aber schon
wofür gleich ob es sich lohnen wird
jetzt kann ein vorbeigelaufen
wetten
witten
seht ihr die leute richtig klappt und
wir sitzen ja oben
die wand spielen
bei den zeiten verlass
zu heftig
heute verhandelt habe ich mal kurz aus
und flüchteten wasserkraftwerk sind halt
eben durch die ganzen existieren
gerichtsstreit leute oder kuranyi beim
hören dass leute da waren der weinfeste
und jetzt mit 100 aus gesehen links
richtig richtig spannend und ich freue
mich richtig mitnehmen kann
bleibt
ein patient mit
red
die ganze blabla undercover goldes ja
ich meine sonnenbrille und kämpfen mit
den taliban
auf jeden fall können wir kurze pause
von der schau weil die ein bisschen
dieses gründlich geworden ist so ein
bisschen machen alina drin
leute ich hab einfach das glaube ich
bekomme das magische garn richtig geile
party will dafür aus mit gesehen und
sagen dass dieses spiel
a
wulff
so leute
das gamescom video days wochenende ist
vorbei ich hoffe es nicht zu windig hier
willy graber noch wissen auf dem balkon
vom lieben ramon und ich weiß noch
zusammenfassend gestern nach dem
videodreh ist waren wir noch ein
bisschen draussen mit patrick roth pils
und korn crafter und natürlich kein
kocht in meinem bruder sich nur
umgezogen
nach dem video das war richtig cool ich
hoffe der video kannst du bist nicht
dumme rübergebracht richtig spaß gemacht
ich glaube es findet es egal tut mir
einfach es jetzt zu wenig ist ich fasse
mich kurzweilig gefallen das einen
daumen nach oben da schickt ihr dann hab
ich glaub ich packe meine nicht die
kommentare seien die beschreibung
nächsten video das produkt und schreibt
rainer peters anwalt